why
so carol danvers is first introduced to
us and Marvel superheroes volume 1 issue
number 13 and March of 1968 but the way
that her character is entry introduced
to us and the time in which she's
introduced to us is very interesting
here for a couple reasons
the first reason is because while Marvel
had demonstrated a very progressive
attitude regarding races when it came to
the sexes they were actually lagging
behind for the most part people look at
DC Comics when it comes to the idea of
the establishment of the roles of sexes
within comics especially when you look
at wonder woman who had been created
about 20 years before Carol Danvers
but when Carol Danvers was introduced to
us the United States was in the midst of
not only the civil rights movement but
also second wave feminism and indeed
Carol Danvers is a reflection of this
now to step away from this comic for a
second second wave feminism was of
course the era of feminism that had come
about around the mid 1960s and had more
or less began to fade out by the late
1970s but in 1968 second wave feminism
was going strong and this is the era
which most people associate with the
archetype so to speak of feminism or
they look at women who are stepping away
from gender specific roles women who are
moving away from being relegated to the
household and taking on roles that had
previously been largely occupied by men
not with regards to this story what we
had seen is that Captain Marvel Marvel
was attempting to try to find some way
to figure out what was going on with the
several attempts that had been made on
his life by an enemy that he was unaware
of now this enemy was a Kree named yon
wrong this Kriya had the intention of
simply eliminating Captain Marvel for
his own purposes but what we had seen is
that as yon wrong was prepared to kill
or I guess to deal the killing blow to
Marvel that a plane had flown in between
the two of them and what I did it had
been shot and blown up and what a
Captain Marvel had realized is that this
individual inside of the plane was a man
named Walter Lawson and that Walter
Lawson was
as an expert in missile guidance and was
headed towards Cape Canaveral for
reassignment and so what Marvel
determines here what he comes to the
understanding of is that if he
undertakes the guise of Walter Lawson
and travels to Cape Canaveral he may
come a step closer to figuring out who
it is that's trying to kill him from
here he arrives at Cape Canaveral and
this is when we're introduced to Carol
Danvers and Carol Danvers in terms of
her initial introduction to us is
exactly what you would expect in the
sense that she is a reflection again a
feminism at the time Carol Danvers is in
an authoritative position she has people
that answer directly to her she is a
confident woman she is an attractive
woman and she's an intelligent woman she
is a reflection of what it is that women
were striving for in terms of society's
perception of them with the the instance
of second wave feminism and what we find
here is that NASA has discovered a Kree
sentry and this is in fact the same Kree
sentry that had previously been stumbled
upon by the Fantastic Four during our
discussion about the Inhumans and of
course Marvel having undertaken the role
of Walter Lawson meets with Carol
Danvers and Carol Danvers initially
thinks that something's up
she initially thinks that something may
be wrong here that he may not either be
telling them everything or that there's
something that he's hiding and this is
where Carol Danvers shows that she
stands alone in terms of the perception
of women and comics when it came to the
idea of gender roles when it came to the
idea of women in comics during this time
for the most part women were relegated
to sidekicks when we were relegated to
background characters women were never
on the same level as the male
counterparts or even males in general
with end comics and so where we see
Carol Danvers say that she's going to
undertake the role of trying to find out
what it is that Walter lawson is hiding
previously a woman in the comics would
have simply just reported this to a male
superior or she would have told a male
superhero like Captain America or Thor
something like that she would not have
gone on her own to try to figure out
what it is and again this is why Carol
Danvers stands alone because she is a
reflection of feminism in comics and she
is a confident woman who is attending to
how to find the answers by herself from
here we see that Yan raw discovers that
the century has been found by NASA and
decides to reactivate this century and
because this century as it explains was
created by the Cree to ensure that its
Empire survives and to do what a can to
destroy all opposition it begins to go
awry and begins to destroy virtually all
human opposition within Cape Canaveral
and so what we see is that Marvel
discards his identity of Walter Lawson
and begins to go into conflict with with
the century now this is where Captain
Marvel begins to branch off because
again when we had had our discussion
about where to start with various Marvel
superheroes we had talked about how
characters like Thor had been introduced
and journey into mystery and that rather
than Thor getting his own solo series
journey into mystery was simply just
converted into Thor series and so it was
called journey into mystery and then for
issue number whatever that issue was
with Captain Marvel this was different
Captain Marvel and the story actually
continued with his own solo series in
Captain Marvel volume 1 issue number 1
and what we see is it for the most part
we just pick up right back where we left
off but this for the most part is where
a lot of people look at the idea of
Carol Danvers and say that Marvel began
to drop the ball because what we saw
here was that Carol Danvers were
previously being identified in a single
issue as a strong confident woman now
became more or less a subservient love
interest of Captain Marvel not in the
sense that she would acquiesce to his
every need but in the sense that she was
a appeared very helpless in a lot of
circumstances and really just wanted to
gain the affections of Marvel now again
people would argue that more than a
Carol Danvers being helpless in this
circumstance was due more to the fact
that she was observing a fight between
two individuals that had a lot more
power than her which is true to this
degree she had no power she was a normal
human but as we'll see when we get into
her solo series miss Marvel issue number
one that this trend of her being a
character that is both mentally and I
guess emotionally not on par with her
male counterparts will continue and that
this idea will begin to stretch forward
with her character so
Marvel will effectively have a very
intelligent strong confident woman but
will instead of allowing her to become a
major character and a major female
character at that and Marvel Comics will
begin to relegate her to a background
character once more so while Carol
Danvers continued to make various
appearances over the course of Captain
Marvel solo comic the actual character
miss Marvel didn't appear until January
of 1977 now at this point in time Carol
Danvers and the character Miss Marvel
were under the control of Gary Conway
and what Gary Conway did is he wrote the
character in such a way to where it was
more or less a metaphor for the struggle
of feminists at the time what he did is
he split the essence with the character
miss marvel and Carol Danvers in half
and so we got this sort of dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde kind of situation now this
wasn't a dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
situation in the sense that Carol
Danvers or Miss Marvel was the evil
counterpart of the other it was more or
less a situation where neither one
remembered the actions of the other
neither one really knew what was going
on now the reason why Gary Conway had
done this was explained in the back of
Miss Marvel issues number one and two
with the misprints which of course were
a series of articles that were written
by Gary Conway as a way for us to
understand the character of Carol
Danvers a little bit better and what he
had said was that Carol Danvers and Miss
Marvel's quest for identity was a direct
reflection of the quest of women and
second wave feminism to achieve equality
to achieve liberation and to find a
wrong a form of identification for women
as a whole at the time but while this
was also taking place we saw what would
be the the kind of seeds that would lead
to miss Marvel becoming a background
character to where this strong feminist
concept would begin to take a backseat
towards the more traditional method of
portraying women in comics in the sense
that her outfit was largely indicative
of Captain Marvel's outfit which was
really a homage at least in terms of how
some women looked at it as Marvel saying
that she was more or less just a clone
of Captain
well in addition we saw that the
villains that she had gone against were
never major villains they weren't
massive and scale she never really went
against characters in her solo series
like Doctor Doom it was more or less
just thugs and and muggers and robbers
and for the most part street-level
characters now by issue number three
Chris Claremont had taken over the
character of Carol Danvers and what we
saw was a continuation of these themes
we saw continuation of the kind of
villain she would face as well as this
dichotomy between Carol Danvers and Miss
marvel
it wasn't until volume 1 issue number 19
with the story Mirror Mirror that we
actually learned what had happened and
we saw this male ding of personas
between Carol Danvers and Miss Marvel
and what we learn in this story is that
Ron and the accuser has arrived to
capture both Marvel and Miss marvel at
the request of the supreme intelligence
and over the course of the comic the
Supreme intelligence reveals to us
exactly how it was that Miss Marvel came
to be what we learn is that somewhere
along the line while the conflict was
taking place between Captain Marvel and
Yann raagh that miserable Errol Danvers
was exposed to the powers of the sight
magnetron now the psyche magnetron was a
device that was capable of turning
dreams into reality and Carol Danvers
despite her strong feminist tendencies
had looked at Captain Marvel as a hero
she had looked at him as somebody she
would that she wanted to aspire to and
so what the SOG magnetron did was
interpret this as the wishes of Carol
Danvers and so it took the physiology of
Captain Marvel copied it and then
transposed it on to the to the human
physiology of Carol Danvers making her a
perfect combination of Kree and human
which in turn gave her the abilities
that she possessed now again as the
stories continued as the Miss Marvel
events continued she maintained this
element of fighting street-level
characters and again this is why a lot
of people look at Carol Danvers and say
that while she had a great start as a
strong lead female character in Marvel
Comics that in the end she began to be
relegated to a background character that
Marvel had moved away from this
a progressive stance of feminism and the
comics and in turn had gone back to its
traditional roots of the portrayal of
women and comics now for the most part
we're actually going to bring this video
to an end here and in the second video
we're going to pick up on Miss Marvel
with her involvement and the Avengers
and the x-men and with the Avengers
we're going to touch on Avengers issue
number 200 which may consider to be one
of the most controversial stories to
have ever been written in the history of
Marvel Comics with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys
for away I
my